good morning believe nation today's
message is build things organically over
to you Hobson misread school TV go I
just have my whole plan laid out and
yeah I do whatever the hell I want if I
don't do it it's cuz I didn't want to do
it so these labels don't impress me I am
the label now I am labeling them
whatever my facebook everything I run I
just do whatever I want and I and I
still get the same amount of exposure as
these even sometimes more exposure than
a lot of these people in these big
labels when they put stuff out and the
label doesn't know I promoted or build a
buzz and I'm just over here sitting
right here drinking this goddamn
cranberry juice posted on Facebook and
the [ __ ] gets a million views fast and
it's just they're just like how you do
that Jay well how does he do this cuz I
built it organically and learn how to
rap I talk to my fans I'm a humble dude
I um yeah just just building everything
from the ground up not bigger coating
anything I'm not being fake about
anything I'm not putting on a fake image
i'm not having other stars cosine me or
being next to people just like I look
cooler and making people think that I'm
doping what I am it's just it's the
realness I'm just hops in the guy who
knows how to rap and I be online
promoting myself and i started this
career and i got my little team with
funk volume and we're all doing it I
love this message and if you look at the
success of my youtube channel it's been
because everything has been built really
organically it started off as me wanting
to share stories and advice and wisdom
that I had learned from other famous
entrepreneurs and I told their stories
and then you guys started asking me
questions and so I made videos around
that and then I added the ants presso
series and the music series in the top
10 series and all of the things that
either I wanted selfishly for myself or
that you guys were asking for even if
you look at all the people that we cover
in the ins presso series in the top 10
series it all comes from you it all
comes from requests I was talking to
Nina last night and she was keeping
track of all
10 request that we have on the channel
and we have over 700 names of people
that you guys want us to cover right
that's two years worth of content even
if we never got another request from you
guys and so it's been an amazing
experience it's been an amazing journey
and everything has been built
organically based on something that I
really love or something that you guys
are asking me for and so you can apply
the same principles to your business
build things that you desperately want
that you can use in your life that can
help others and then listen to the
feedback from the people who are using
your products or services on how you can
get better and continue to build things
to help them do that your business will
just grow it'll grow organically and you
have a lot of success of these so the
question the day today is how do you
build things organically leave it in the
comments below and I'll join the
discussion thank you so much for
watching have an amazing day continue to
believe and I'll see you again tomorrow
morning for another shot a vinspresso
spray so keep me go